arneg speaker is arborio and ruben block
and principal did scientist at a
greenhouse
aan en you tell you more about this
company mainly in c
workshop wat is pockets marry my virgin
afternoon
en en de arm unstable nice around xlii
van citri on and again i figure houses
were much and joy
ar discussions about statistics debt collection
in french zal have high expectations
tanks dennis
zo al die telling you we bit about skoda
yeti problems in the field of
advertising and show you how you could
soft musical instruments fair bills and
using pie en citri
zo lets  first the ferry brief introduction
for company info
gigi fix the controls of my flight deck
yes it's working so far the brief
introduction by law company rhino's is
the digital marketing agency base in
eindhoven in en sittard and 5 years ago
buyer at the library ii and iii typical
holding of marketing company's xlii one
of the biggest globally zo greenhouse s
al is bizarre reactions classifications
technologies and the ma  rketing
technology sana
joost koster girls we do double u
pien at work
zo before the start occasionally a
problem
my first need to take you choose and
terminology zo
first en impressionism en islower
points on to the browser if there is user
second
conversion in the  specific objectif or
recognize one
she is this design comes home by the
advertiser like this shampoo this can be
a user purchasing santing and the website
or these things specific web page
dare you freaks i have a lot i have
is a setting for that is also a pain
switch sets a maximum amount of
at that can be shown to each user zo
lets
the research question zo this is a
tassel net ff thai scopias in jacket
bridge to be more more or less like what
is the top of mount of impressions
per user de op  de baixar kon versions
well this might sound like a very well
defined fiches crash en wat john de
stolp
i will show you this is not specific
not yet
zo what do you aim if i get social
research ques  tion of course who taker
historical better and who start exploring
what weekend see content this so first
headline or the place let you might get of
the detail and at first sight this might
look amazing the calls free can see this
clear to make
innside is plots  however i should not be
the sea eagle session start thinking
critical you build is suddenly der
santing arles de we to be one of them is
off the optimum music values ​​steep
decline in the conversion mobility
so what's how minifig week at quay the
jump negative  effect my show and
extra impression would you mind think this
makes sense
in bottles size too much de and users
will never gather
and they won't want to buy there products
in humor
ahava refreshing unrest and critical who
wants to see this is is little bit too  extreme
or a negative effect it is not very
likely that this happens in reality
moreover and more importantly if i look
at the force plot
down mister michel i see that is so just
in death wish you may t  he heavens much
as forty with which that label the show user
and this is such a thing of course that they
feel i cannot be true and can never be a
good thing to show such a large amount
of tedster user zo
what is happening lets look at  their
goal zo graph first of all when you're
looking at the classical
confounding problem anyway sun and
surf very angry vauxhall her active users
go to be on the internet in general that
influence but the amount of impressions
dat weekend surf to this user
en  the mobility of conversion
however this is not thing to do with that
opted effect or a press and song
conversion kit itself
so far spheres confounding problem that in
the specification of this other poles and
this is the kohl's of what looks
like for negative effect about it so
be is happening at wembley wenneke
pain was a user hash conversion for
shampoo purchase because in a website
who explore this user for the rest if
i a pain so actually what's happening
in the data is that  the users are most
interested in a product or never get a
large amount of impressions and disco
like to take via vers chrome negative
effect all in fact
this is necessary to effect it so what
we do luckly week and do instruments
ferryboat
zo by louis  not iou's instrumental
further so in inverse place so
the goal and standard is you are using a
random controlled trials would a
discussion no who tests it and who his
weekend goal is here is
beagles week and hero exec lido an ebi
test to mirror your motive impression
weekend for users to specifically
certain amount of impressions
alef er op i can do is to make the test
special frequency cap zo the maximum
amount of impressions and user can get
and this is a good thing
louef perfect shadow your instrument of
hairball analysis  share with you i will
explain you in a xlite so what do you do
perfect instrument here first of all the
cosby do abbey test
weekend i showed that a instruments
frequency cap  is not confoundedly
in our head confounders double you
so this is the casu buticosus wii
controller and the masai ant of the
experiment but about mobile will have set
free cathy cat is in french impressions
and impressions
is influence in the conversion mobility
ficus i have there instrument  is not having
the direct effect to the conversion
mobility they are this other property
that makes between perfect kees through
wfm very strong instrument here so lets
go back to the research crash and so the
quasimodo's buddies that optimal month
of impressions could maximize it
versions
so very good so biology with critical
and quarter of percentages julissi and
when so out cozy and friends this
instruments furnaces been used a lover
you feel i think about
is the avatar's is as in discretion beagles
they want to set the freaky cap with the op
the new level
then read only to use the instrumental
ver wil en and so there is already
buys i have if we can simply use the
bills of vebi test  to it self so because
i is the tinka boss in sean thingy
know die test directly it is something
that come the influence in the first
place and might be your in fact
invest in the defensive are you
up to
at first and other case this is
basically  the case
guido longer the feels is 4 bantu article
glow effect to change sharding
algorithms
both the kennel tester radley
unnumbered impressions
the consul in fact of impressions to the
conversion mobility they I say I do this
number by those who do not do so
implementation
so chat dive into the  did generation
function zoey fmx my fusion cap and the
mac formative impressions there about seven
den ersten base conversion mobility so
die pending our potential months of
patient a user can get
so busy crea weekend built this is
the part of the popo billet i30 nothing to
do  we de kon she wefact de sec en t' wi
that die effect would this is in fact the
two effects sizes de everyone together
and by system that for
ow  even distribution and beyond
potential impressions this santing week
in the control would be your chance idea so so
buse in is not easily distribute it
ayfer the distribution on the ficus that
caps is easily distributor
varieties this is where i can control the i
die test
so how you  you see violinist i did
airbed be used as they are the de cheeks
simulation
3 for that is that wie not access
assimilation to show you the wie
xlii kinget and bars you will now as in
reality
the tour effect sar and rob surfs so
furnishing relation bios  a million
caterpillar so lets sign look and today t that
is generate it so that you can clearly
see here is you this from blocks to
frequency caps and within those buckets
it in that it is a maximum to my
for those impressions
name of users in  f convergence and
divergence a simply the user's miasma
man of convergence is datasheet week
single by impressions and week and group is
by function cap and life rounds
percentage and if you have the audacity and  tim
plots about him even with the you look at
the impressions heard frequency cap so
lets person who finds also already read
will wit
so you never do instruments
further analysis we the single trident and
a single instrument the calculation is
is photos
you simply times try  die of the
increase in commercial popo buttocks tea
bring die instruments close-up divided
by the increase in the air treatment of
instrument coschap zo lets go to a quick
simple to show you how this works in a
guy graf zo week en kalk leder works
effect  of free can see
impressions which might be sure
damn i can calculate the indirect effect
of frequency cap to the conversion
mobility beach white beach europoint she
wrote to them i can just to the the
vision to get the en bias testing with
perfect for an impressions through the
conversion mobility
however i do not even single instrument
in a single frame and there be cut
scriptures der ven levels of the amoun  t
of impressions so enjoy charlize this
message a little bit
would there effect pita christ express my
bridges the amount of and passion candy
i will be treating
so weekend simplified i did this as
the try the tee of having in an arm
out of impressions jets hired  a ficus
i have is here oh so i think was this
one out and for simplicity
who will call the increase a conversion
michel delta ai
ritual leivers for the simple
repression zo death to the calculations
for doing this calculations who do that
just jets not parsi tree  the cause you
can simply generate a stereo
distributing
using the bita distributions pension
here with first lets do this plot about
what it looks like for a impressions en
afrika cup zo in de topman you can see
you suddenly very agree impressions mike when
you're looking  at historical better
so learn i wish you clear the sea a
peak in the middle and third negative
effect for the looks like a lover is who
has be running an experiment  to get a
frequency cap then be in the tsiet that
the detail looks quite differently and
grows up and down the levels and cb drag the
first impression looks to be most
effective with the plateau the sexes lily
dynasties negative effect so lets pushed
calculation and look at the  plot of
judgment and het so perfect arrogi zo pc
this looks quite maize in flower you see
the floor values ​​and special i want to
en two impressions weekend sidar sms of
kwai fong
however if i get to the high and patient
she can see the raven ryan's  kon
riebeeck something like becoming shaky and
drizzle step ifr is extreme distress
something we can take into production is
correct simply to take you and you see
actually quite form negative reasult wal
in fact this my girl i be used as a high
variance and as intros that a  negative
effect some
new bolts variance so week and make
some assumptions
this is carnet de hive modeling is a
brand in the variance by en stroking or something
what are you coming to do let's make something
about  there parametric form of
delta in which is the increasing
commercial problem wil v
zo here again the finer bit medium if
you look at t-mobile it looks quite a
lot like bit logistic regression bit
van de finse
would de fans is so 11 a
before the  logistic regression wedgwood
multiplying
the geocache and the who snap do you do this
if you can limit its function in
devon that are yet to come
up to the population of bang we dit sommer
els zo this is simply the new limmen see
this site estimate with her 11 akira
using this per with i
for week and the fine time sees four
models which puts like this
and let's take a look at reasult wel this
looks much faster then these beagles
week and sidar you will be there still quite
clear to  the true value is met de venge
is much much much much more
zo this is extra by making some
parametric assumptions that who effects
photo effects in bloom this weekend
introduction however if i look at seven
impressions level
and who s  he clearly the brain of can or
bias candy in me if it though your
sex life
very close up vebi around the 2 pers and
person language and this is not something that
i becomes so what he because the goal is the
software
hermetica functional bits and this is
where week and influence harlekino mobile so
critters i check lycee mobile offers
don't matter how the higher order
parameters should you put won
see what you would consent to next i would
be there is free make a model a little
bit more flexible
by allowing  for sea this specific purpose
amount of impressions twf zo by relaxing
so my littlebits math implements
a parasite free like this
i have a new leaf bits looks much
better you can see no de too far a
soup bowl a higher winds
fiction order impressions of getting
higher
bit  can still see that is not is
xlii extremely shaky
a special space did not know frise
lands firth plots
would this santing on i can apply and
practice
zo charlie come on back to the resear  ch
issue and where we were looking for from
carnival optimal
to effect and vector bici here it is
mebius there own way of thinking about it
to start with
just about not clearly see is that the versus
most effective and we so effective
blades becoming less and less and  tail
started zero so mee the beach your idea how
did it go and optimum
the thinking about it like a ok how
much is it purfessional expert with
wings implement aspects in this in
tubingen algorithm so lets push recap
so wanting holland the show you so bring
can use  instruments ver bos so you can
vote you are not refn bias sms or
console effects and this candy or support
to test the free point in which he offers is
the radley
about germany thing you know
who test it implement it free point
at 1000 influence de  and the car could
radley
[ __ ] ar instrument and you see all
check whether you're sure that is not
more correct isel's or jp test that you are
interested in i if this might be
something y  ou their influence and this performs
free moment you there executing
so the contours conclusions instrument
furby's can be applied to watch
specifically cedar
however it as a life is to chalice suffered and
bias test it of console effects for
something we can take the test it yourself
when went into problems for variance
you can start making parametric
assumptions about chips in your waist and
view science